you
you
Thanks so yeah I'm Peter this is Kevin
we work at Adobe on this thing called
brackets how many people have heard of
brackets before to set it curiosity
awesome how many people have actually
used it ever yes that's what we like to
hear so for everyone else
brackets is an open-source code editor
that we're building it's MIT licensed
it runs the desktop back app but it's
actually written in JavaScript and HTML
and CSS and for that reason we think of
it as not just a code editor we think of
it as almost sort of a platform or a
sandbox for building to enable
experimentation in sort of code editor
ideas sort of new functionality new
experimental exotic you know features
for writing code tools for development
code we've done a whole bunch of
different experiments ourselves some of
them are built into brackets we've
shipped some of these ideas as brackets
extension some of them are kind of still
experimental and ongoing and we're gonna
focus on two of them today HTML live
development and something called Theseus
and we're gonna sort of go pretty deep
under the hood and explain how these
crazy new editing ideas actually work
and for the first one of those Kevin's
going to talk about live development
yeah so brackets for some time has had
live CSS development so basically if
you're editing a CSS stylesheet as you
make changes to the style sheet that
changes automatically show up in your
browser which is really cool
but see it with CSS is fairly
straightforward because you could just
replace a little stylesheet and the
browser will get it right with HTML
that's a bit harder and that's why it
gets to be interesting and hopefully
you'll enjoy hearing how that works but
let me show off what it looks like let's
see so here I am in the browser window
I've got a reveal.js presentation that
we're sweet looking at on the left side
we've got the live development stuff so
I should we do a demo sure why not yeah
so you can see that it's actually really
fun writing a real presentation where
you can do live changes to it like that
and see the changes as you as you make
them so let's talk about how that
actually works and what we had to do so
basically the idea here is that we want
to update the use update the page as the
user types we want to do it quickly for
two reasons one so that the changes show
up in the browser quickly and also so
that the typing speed is still fast
so that that's important to keep those
both going swiftly and so we also want
to make a reasonably minimal change to
the page so that if they have JavaScript
running or something else running on
that page that's not static content then
we want to make it so that just the
static content has changed as they're
typing so that is what we wanted to do
how hard can that be
let's see if we look at the HTML or XML
differece search that's been done
because basically what we're doing is
we're finding the differences daniel
Arenberg brothers paper is surveying the
research and he said but the algorithms
are all kind of difficult to understand
and yeah they they were this particular
paper proved to be a nice starting point
for us detecting changes in XML
documents it's efficient for a speed and
memory there's some loss of quality
which means your dips might be a bit
larger but that wasn't quite the
important thing to us and an important
thing too is it has a move operation and
we'll see why you want moves later on so
as we started implementing it we found a
number of differences between what that
paper was talking about and what we need
to do the biggest difference is that in
our environment we we're not just
dipping to static files on disk we
actually have this code editor that we
can store information about the document
as you're as you're writing your
document so what we do is we use this
feature we use an editor called code
mirror as the main editing surface in
brackets and it has a feature called
marks which basically lets you mark a
range of text and code mirror will keep
that mark up to date as the users
editing so if they insert some more text
that mark kind of stretches out so what
we do behind the scenes is we basically
create marks for each tag that go from
the beginning of the start tag to the
end of the end tag and we give it an ID
so each tag is going to get its own
unique ID and we propagate that all the
way through to the browser so that we
want to when we want to send dips across
to the browser we can edit based on
these IDs that were assigning so the
user never even has to see those so the
basic process that we go through is we
try to find the affected part of the
tree see if we can do maybe a partial
work on the tree we tokenize and parse
the document generate a bunch of edits
sudden those across the browser and then
apply them the browser
I'm not going to talk about the last two
they're they're not quite as interesting
for this purpose but I'll focus on those
first three so the first step in this
bunch of code here is basically just
figuring out is it a fairly simple
change and on that second line is it a
dangerous edit and basically idea where
there is that is it something that could
structurally change the document because
we found that there's a lot of edge
cases there to try and figure out can we
safely do just part of the tree if we
see a less than sign we just give up we
say no and we're gonna we're going to
just go ahead and do a full diff but a
lot of times as user typing you can
actually just focus on part of the tree
and work from there so for example in
that mark example I showed the h2 tag
there if you're just editing text in
there we can and you don't put a less
than sign or something we can say oh
yeah we just need to look at that h2 tag
and run a diff and see what see if
there's been a change of the text for
example and send that across so it's
much much faster especially in a big
document so the tokenizing parsing step
we started with this particular parsers
tokenizer because it had the right kind
of api for us and we've made a lot of
changes to it since then that are
specific to our need but but basically
we read the tokens as soon as the
document becomes invalid we actually
just stop updating we wait until it gets
valid again and then we make then we
start running dips again and then we
match up the the stuff that we're
reading from the document from the
document text we match that up with the
tokens sorry from the IDs that code
mirror is keeping for us and then we
build what we call a simple Dom it's not
actually it's our own little simple
JavaScript objects it's not native Dom
objects so we just have these simple Dom
objects and we calculate these hashes so
we'll take a look at what the simple Dom
looks like and I'll and you can see the
hashes here so basically if we have this
sort of example paragraph it's got you
know an attribute on it there are some
text nodes underneath it there's a an M
tag underneath it it's got its own text
node and so you know you have your
typical tree structure we had IDs to all
the elements that we talked about
already there those pass all the way
through and we have these signatures and
the signatures are really handy because
especially the subtree signature because
what it lets us do is
say you have you make a change to the
body of your of your page and in your
HTML page has you know you've got your
HTML element at the root and then you've
got a head and a body and basically we
look at the head of the new tree and
with the head of the old tree and hey
they've got the same subtree signature
that means we don't need to look at the
head at all so we just stop processing
on that part of the tree so we couldn't
quickly zero in on the part of the tree
that has changed by using these
signatures without having to compare
everything in the tree which makes a big
difference so to do that we use
something called murmur hash 3 which is
a fairly efficient hashing function and
we basically just take the information
that we need to look for the changes so
for like attributes we can just add up
the attribute pairs put them in a string
and then basically use that string and
hash it this is all fairly quick and
works pretty well so to show how this
what kind of edits were actually going
to produce here I'll use this simple
edit example where it's basically gonna
take the high J's conf paragraph and the
we're merging paragraphs paragraph and
we're gonna remove the paragraph tag
between them so so what we do is we
start off with a Dom that looks like a
simple Dom it looks like this so section
these IDs of course are gonna be
different than what we see in the actual
browser but section is the ID number one
and then we've got an h2 tag is number
two the change that we're gonna end up
making is that that paragraph ID number
four that's gonna get deleted because
we're going to delete the closing tag in
the start tag of the new paragraph and
that M tag that's number five needs to
move under paragraph three so we end up
with something that looks like this in
the end
so let's actually do the edit and see
what we get so let me find my example
okay so here's my example and I'm gonna
go ahead and do that so now we have
merged those two paragraphs together and
I have developer tools running against
brackets right here so we can see the
list of edits which communally actually
fits up on the screen perfectly
so the list of edits that we have we got
a few different edit types there are no
attribute edits going on here those are
very simple but we've got this this
first one is kind of mysterious it's
remember nodes and basically this is a
trick
because the way they browser implements
the the changes on its side is it just
looks at these edits as a set of
instructions it does one by one
so when we have a node that we know is
moving for example we will tell the
browser side hey hang on to this node
because you're gonna need it later
so that tag ID one to two to seven that
particular one is going to be that M
node because that's the one that's
that's moving so it's going so the
browser's gonna hang on to that then you
see we got a text replace these are
pretty common because when you're when
you're writing your HTML and it's nicely
structured and indented and all that you
have a lot of white space in there and
so that the text nodes we actually don't
really have a way to refer to them like
we do with elements you know with
elements you can easily just pick them
up by ID but with text node you've got
to actually refer to them sort of to the
relative to the elements that they're
around so that with this text replace
we've got happening here you can see it
has a parent ID so this text node lives
under that particular element and it's
after the element with this other ID and
before the element with this final ID 1
to 2 to 6 so that's really the only way
we could refer to text nodes so we
handle it that way we basically send
across a text replace saying here's your
new content just paste it all in the
next one is the element delete that we
expect for the paragraph that's going
away and then we do have another
whitespace replacement followed by the
element move so that's the so it's tag
ID 1 2 2 2 7 just like we said up at the
remember nodes 1 so basically this is
this is basically the the instruction
that is putting that element in the
place that it needs to be and you can
see it says last child is true and
that's basically telling the browser
just go ahead and do an append child
because this is the last one and then
finally s1 one more bit of white space
because you can never have too much
white space yeah so that's that's
basically what the edits look like so
how do we actually get those at
how do we get that edit list so we
basically have to go from the the old
treat of the new we needed to set up a
set of steps to do that so we start by
looking at the new tree so we take the
root of the new tree and we basically
step through it and compare its
attribute hashes you know those are very
simple changes compare child signatures
so there's a child signature and if the
new trees child signature is different
than the old trees child signature child
signature that means one of its direct
children has has changed and so we've
got another function that's the most
complicated part that generates those
element those edits and then we compare
subtree signatures so if those have
changed then we know we've got more
processing to do in this loop where
we're going to have to compare sub trees
further if there's a change there and
then there's a final extra case where
you might need to add a new element that
didn't exist in the old tree but so the
generating child edits is the
complicated part stuff like text nodes
makes it complicated because you know we
had that whole after ID before ID thing
that we've got to figure out moves are
kind of complicated because you have to
look to see okay this thing was deleted
so on one side where it was deleted in
one place but it's added another place
so we didn't need to kind of keep track
of that and then large structure changes
get complicated so walking through this
a little bit here are the old and new
trees so what happens is that the
section with the idea of one that's
going to get as child signatures
compared it's going to say well okay
there's so there's some difference among
these children here so that's then it's
gonna step through the children of that
element from the new tree and then the
old and compare them item by item and
you can see there's no change the text
node there's no change to the H to no
change paragraph 3 is still the same
element that it was before so that's
that's okay it doesn't actually think
there's a problem there and then that
text node is is the same and then that
we're done actually at that point
looking at the elements in the new in
the new tree so we know if we're done
looking at stuff in the new tree but
there's still stuff in the old tree that
stuff's been deleted so it's going to go
ahead and make a delete for that
paragraph at that point but then it
knows
that as it as it goes back to that main
loop it says okay well so paragraph
three has a change to its children so
it's going to go and cycle through
paragraph threes children so you see
there that the text node hi J s conf is
still the same but the M node is new so
and actually in this case the old tree
has run out of has run out of nodes to
compare but the new tree still has some
so you know those those are additions
that have happened but in the case of
this M node it knows that this M no it
existed in the old tree but it just
exists here now so it knows that's a
move and that's how it ends up making a
move edit for it and that's the basic
process it goes through you know each of
those differences that it spots it has a
different function that it's going to
call that generates the edits and it you
know will run some extra checks to see
when there's moves and things like that
it adds it basically has to do the
bookkeeping like when it spots an
element that it's that is appropriate
for using as a text after ID for example
it then sets it and hangs onto that data
that elements ID so that it can refer to
that in future text note edits and
things like that so it goes through this
this general process and there's a lot
of code to make that work can we have a
lot of test cases to make it work right
so performance why is that was what
we've been working on this print I
should mention this feature is actually
new in brackets sprint 31 which is the
sprint we're in right now so in a few
days we're gonna have a build out that
actually includes this feature right now
it's it's not a shipping feature but it
but it will be in a few days
so this sprint we've actually been
working on performance so you so it
seems like tokenizing and parsing and
hash computation in diff generation
sounds like that can actually actually
get kind of expensive but it turns out
that that's not the expensive part so it
always pays to measure before you
optimize it turned out that the code
mirror mark stuff was where we really
saw our bottlenecks and in fact a
specific area of it was was when you're
trying to find where the mark range is
in the text code mirror has to do a lot
of work to do that because basically
when you say get me the positions of
this mark it then goes has to basically
linearly scan through the document to
find
where the end of that mark is from the
beginning and figure out those positions
again recompute them so that's that gets
kind of expensive and that overwhelmed
everything else we had going on so all
we had to do is basically cache that and
that made that made all the difference
in the world as far as performance was
concerned so you can read more about
this research on our wiki if you go look
at the pages list you'll find the HTML
Dom data structure research if you're
interested in further detail on this and
of course it's open source so you can
also see the code Peter you want to take
it away all right so we're gonna switch
gears a little bit and talk a little bit
about the JavaScript at it inside of the
world actually more specifically
JavaScript debugging mr. project we're
working on called Theseus it's actually
a research project we're doing in
collaboration with this guy Tom Lieber
from MIT so I'm very excited to be
talking about this because I think
between the two of us we have a monopoly
on the big hair for code editor
developers it's a good combo so Theseus
is a type of omniscience debugger anyone
heard that term before omniscient
debugging right so sometimes these are
called historical debuggers and
basically means that it's a it's a
debugger that has captured a deep
information about the entire history of
execution so rather than just knowing
the state when you're positive
breakpoint it knows everything that's
happened up until leading up to that
moment in time so some omniscient
debuggers use that to provide a step
backwards command so in addition to
being able to step line by line forwards
in the code you can also reverse time
and rewind line by line yeah and that's
a pretty cool feature there's some some
newer omniscient debuggers that are
experimenting with the idea of trying to
visualize the entire flow of execution
rather than just showing you a sliver of
time that you can step forward and
backward they try to show you everything
all together so if anyone's seen this
demo from Brett Victor that's in that
vein we also have a research project
going on with brackets called insta bug
that's along the same lines and then
some admission debuggers rather than try
to show you all the information at once
they sort of try to create a query ball
set of data so you can sort of filter it
down and you can ask questions about why
things happen that's the category that
Theseus sort of falls into so let me
actually go ahead and show you a demo of
it
what was the shortcut again command
option okay so yeah so I have TCS up and
running here it's a brackets extension
and I have this really simple fake web
page it has a fake network call because
you don't want to rely on the Wi-Fi and
when I click that button here if you
watch the numbers in the in the
left-hand column there you'll see the
numbers actually update every time I
click the button and you can see there's
this asynchronous sort of fake network
delay so you'll actually see that the
the thing making the network request
takes happens first and then you'll see
the second number for the callback
increment a second later you see that
kind of pause if I click this Clear
button you'll see the number down here
jumping around and you can see as I
click it it's updating pretty much
instantaneously so it's it's very fast
it's basically real time gathering this
information so it can do much more than
that though so for example if I click
one of these calls
I can see down here essentially sort of
a timeline of all the times this method
has been called and it's actually
captured the argument values here for
every invocation of that function so it
knows the timestamp and those the
argument values I can actually go look
at the stack trace that led to that call
it remembers everything that happened
more than that I can actually begin
selecting other functions and I can see
it essentially a threaded view of the
chain of causation that led to these
functions being called and if you stop
and think this is actually a pretty
impressive case if you look at this pair
because the callback is not being
literally directly called by this get
info function it's being called
asynchronously later kind of as a side
effect so it's sort of indirectly being
called and yet theseus is actually
stitching this together in sort of a
threaded view so it knows that this
specific call to get info at this time
led to this specific call to the call
back later and you can basically add as
many functions as you want to this query
and they'll all get threaded together so
it knows the arguments of the the
network call that led to the arguments
of the call back later even though
there's this kind of asynchronous delay
separating them
0/3 there you go okay so one thing that
I don't have time to show in detail it's
pretty cool about these days is that I
can actually do this for server-side
JavaScript code if it's running a node
as well as code running in the browser
on the client-side it can actually
gather data about both simultaneously so
if you have your client-side code
invoking a network call that causes code
to run a node then asynchronously later
causes more callbacks to run on the
client-side in the browser that threaded
view can actually show you the whole
timeline of all that stuff happening
interleaved both server-side and
client-side together it's pretty awesome
I think another milestone that we
reached recently with Theseus is you can
actually use it to debug brackets itself
which is pretty exciting cuz bracket
this is a huge code base it's megabytes
and megabytes of JavaScript code so sort
of shows that this really scales up
pretty well
so let's actually talk about how it
works now fundamentally the way it works
is by injecting instrumentation into the
JavaScript code it uses the Suprema
JavaScript parser uses an open source
project called falafels which is
essentially a parse tree walker and it
uses a modified version of J's hint to
get information about variable scoping
that whole stack of stuff is driven by
fondue which is basically a spin-off
project from Theseus that's just the
instrumentation part so it's sort of a
headless piece of JavaScript code that
takes JavaScript is input injects the
instrumentation and gives you the output
modified JavaScript so Theseus basically
asks fondue to generate an instrumented
copy of all your JavaScript code and
then it serves that up from a local node
server so similar to how the
instrumented HTML is served up for the
live HTML that Kevin talked about this
is serving up instrumented JavaScript
code so that's running in the browser
then brackets or Theseus inside of
brackets actually connects over to the
browser on a WebSocket to retrieve the
data that was gathered by that
instrumentation and then it's visualized
in the brackets UI and those the inline
annotations and the bottom panel that
you saw before
so let's actually look at what that
instrumentation looks like the simplest
and first thing that we want to do is
instrument every time a function is
called so we know when it was called
what the call stack was and what the
arguments were so every function the
beginning of the body in the end of the
function body gets these annotations
added that essentially just record what
function was called
there's argument values captures the
this value if there was one and captures
a timestamp so this is sort of a
simplified form of it there's actually a
little more boilerplate that it adds in
practice to do things like catching
exceptions and all that but this is
basically what it does but that's not
enough to do that sort of threaded view
where you see exactly which function
call led to which other function call
for that we need to do something more
complicated because if you think of
something like this so you could have
more than one call to a function in
different parts of the code base and the
the trace enter call inside the body of
bar doesn't know anything about which
particular place in the code it was
called from and it also doesn't know
which you would like to know which
invocation of the calling function led
to it so we can actually chain them all
together showing the argument values of
the caller and the callee all threaded
together so to do that we actually wrap
every single function invocation in the
whole code base and pass it through this
sort of function invoke our helper and
what that basically does is it's just
going to call bar apply with the
argument values but it's going to pass
along this identifier so we can remember
which place in the code base it's a
unique identifier for each call to bar
so it basically tells you the line
number it was called from and on top of
that it's going to capture the
information about the particular
invocation of the outer method foo so
basically what was it whatever was on
the stack frame there so that we know
the timestamp from the caller the
argument values captured from the caller
ID said arow it puts that information
kind of in some global state so that
when you get to the trace enter at the
beginning of the body of bar when it's
called
it can go grab that global State and
basically chain itself on to that sort
of threaded set of function calls
but even this is actually not everything
that we need because we've got this
asynchronous case we want to be able to
understand causation across asynchronous
gaps which is something that's really
hard to debug in traditional debugger so
this is kind of a really a really
important core part of the Theseus
project so we look at something like
this again this outer function foo it's
not calling this inner callback directly
the actual call stack of the inner
callback it's coming out of you know
like an xhr handler that goes through
some jQuery code and then this thing
gets called and the call stack doesn't
capture this relationship to fool at all
so what we do in Theseus is we actually
every place that a callback is created
we wrap
in a wrapper function and that wrapper
function stores on the function object
some state that lets us link it back to
foo and again it's not just the fact
that it's a function named foo with
such-and-such a line number that we want
to link to it's actually the specific
invocation of foo with all the argument
values that happened at that time in a
time sniff it was called in all that so
that information is captured at the time
that the wrapper is generated the
wrapper stores that off as a property on
the function object and then later on
when the wrapper is actually invoked it
can chain itself back to the particular
call to foo that eventually later on led
to the callback being run so this seems
like a crazy amount of instrumentation
being added I mean it's wrapping like
everything and anything right but
actually it's surprisingly it's it
doesn't really impact performance all
that much you know modern JavaScript VMs
are blazingly fast so this actually
works pretty effectively for even fairly
fairly large JavaScript code bases so if
you're interested in reading more about
that there's a great write up there on
the instrumentation in more detail or
you can actually just again go fork the
code and github I feel like it and I
just want to circle back really quick on
this sort of idea of brackets as a
sandbox you know we've been doing all
these kind of experiments you know with
different tooling UI ideas but we didn't
build it's just for us to do experiments
we built this for everyone to be able to
do to experiment with whatever ideas you
have about code editors and JavaScript
tooling and all that sort of stuff
and we think that brackets is a really
great platform to do that kind of stuff
on because it is written in JavaScript
and CSS and HTML so it's all the
standard web tech stack that everybody
already knows and we think that makes it
a really approachable code base to jump
in and begin hacking on begin writing
extensions for etc I'll just show you a
quick example here I won't actually walk
through this code in detail but in in
brackets here this is an extension I
sort of just wrote on the side I just
open an SVG file it basically just
provides an inline preview of the SVG so
it's a much simpler version of the live
preview and if I make edits here like
I'll bring up a color picker and it you
can see the the SVG is actually updating
in real time as I'm changing stuff in
the code so that's kind of something I
think would actually be pretty tricky to
do in a lot of other code editors but be
we have the full power of the Dom and a
real you know WebKit instance at our
disposal for rendering the UI it's
pretty simple to do in brackets if you
look at this you know it's really only
about two screen folds of code just to
get that up and running so you can
really kind of jump in and very quickly
experiment with ideas with in terms of
rich UI that would be hard to do in a
lot of other editors and that's exactly
the kind of experimentation that we want
to empower anyone to be able to play
with and build in brackets so yeah we've
built this sandbox and we want people to
come play in it so please come join our
sandbox
so we have time for maybe one question
is anybody enthusiastic and the audience
got a question okay there's one right
there
thanks for a great talk
if you can't calculate the number of
calls of each parcels I think I could
use this for a search did cotton my
project yeah did what I mean to test on
patents or methods of that never calls
did you say west okay it's the it's hard
with APA we might have to talk afterward
I ask you later okay okay yeah thanks
guys
okay thanks thank you
you